back in the 1980s and 1990s when bill
was actively involved in the day-to-day
operations of microsoft he was a pretty
controversial figure
he was known for being a cutthroat
monopolistic arrogant businessman
modern-day comparisons include
billionaires like mark zuckerberg and
jeff bezos since he stepped away from
being microsoft's ceo in 2000 though it
seems like he wanted to put all of his
money and the power-hungry days behind
him and focus on using his wealth for
the betterment of humanity
over the past 20 years bill gates has
donated over 45 billion dollars to
charity making him one of the most
generous people of all time
considering this it's not surprising
that the media and the public has
celebrated bill's actions labeling him
as the billionaire to look up to
recently though the perception of bill
has shifted once again a quick look at a
recent interview with bill would make it
clear that bill is no longer perceived
to be the good billionaire
so what happened to bill gates
well when it comes to the criticism
against bill gates all of the arguments
boil down to two major categories which
are vaccines and its relationship with a
man named jeff
one of the first papers questioning
bill's actions regarding vaccines was
published in 2008. the core argument of
this paper is that bill's choice of
donations are misguided the researchers
took a look at how the three largest
donors aside from bill gates allocated
their money the world bank the us
government and the global fund all spent
more than 98 of their money on
delivering the services themselves for
instance if we were talking about
vaccinations in africa 98 of their money
went towards acquiring the vaccines
building vaccination facilities and
administrative vaccines with bill gates
however the majority of his donations
went towards research and development
this means that most of the money he
gave away went to private universities
pharmaceutical companies and research
institutions the problem with this is
that these companies and organizations
are often for-profit take a look at
pfizer for instance over the past 15
years they've been able to maintain a
net margin of 20 to 25 percent critics
have argued that due to bill's odd
allocation of funds his philanthropic
efforts may actually enrich western
countries more than they help third
world countries another key attribute
that has drawn criticism towards bill is
his approach on intellectual property if
you're running a tech or media company
protecting your intellectual property
makes perfect sense these companies
spent a lot of time effort and money on
creating their products with the
intention of generating profits so they
don't want competitors ripping them off
and reaping the benefits when it comes
to charity though securing intellectual
property rights is a lot more
questionable
i mean the entire point of charity is to
give products or services away to better
humanity however bill gates has
historically been extremely tight with
his vaccines cures and treatments when
it comes to intellectual property and i
don't just mean taking legal action
against companies and organizations that
impede on his intellectual property
no bill has reportedly bent the rules of
intellectual property to benefit his
foundation through various lobbying
efforts
in the 1990s microsoft aggressively
lobbied for the acceptance of the trips
agreement trips which stands for trade
related aspects of intellectual property
rights set international standards for
intellectual property rights some of its
guidelines are that patents must be
given for a minimum of 20 years and that
pharmaceutical test data must be
protected against quote-unquote unfair
commercial use similarly in 2007
microsoft lobbied the g8 to reinforce
global intellectual property rights by
refusing to let competitors recreate
various vaccines and treatments experts
suggest that bill is limiting the reach
and effectiveness of their effort now
again these vaccines and treatments are
indeed the property of bill's foundation
so it's not like they're overstepping
their rights however bill's refusal to
share has made many question his true
intentions
the final major source of criticism for
bill's foundation has come from
potential unethical medical practices
now let me be clear here
this is a super recent development and
nothing has been confirmed
as of right now this story is simply an
allegation
with that being said those foundation is
facing allegations that they violated
medical ethics with their vaccine
testing
in 2009 bill's foundation funded a
clinical trial that administered an hpv
vaccine to 14 000 tribal girls between
the ages of 10 and 14 in india
however it is alleged that they
conducted the trial without informed
consent of their parents without making
the risk clear and without even telling
the participants or parents that it was
a clinical trial
many of the children not only became
sick but seven of them passed away
now bill's foundation are not actually
the ones that conducted the trial they
simply funded it so even if the
allegations are true it's unclear if
bill's foundation was aware of the
situation
nonetheless much of india was outraged
by this report
as you can see bill's charitable
allocations his tents on intellectual
property and his potential violations of
medical ethics have played the
foundation for decades however it was
not until the pandemic that these
concerns replaced all the light of day
and since then these legitimate concerns
have evolved into full-on conspiracy
theories it all started when bill gates
had a ted talk in april of 2015 where he
described that the next biggest threat
for humanity wasn't wars or asteroids
but rather a pandemic
when the pandemic actually rolled around
most people praised bill for having such
a foresight and regretted that society
more or less ignored his warnings but
there was also a large group of people
that suspected that bill was right not
because he predicted it but because he
planned it this theory basically holds
no substance as there's really no
concrete evidence surrounding the matter
the only reason i'm covering this is
because despite its far-fetched nature
many actually believe it and this is a
major source of the bill gates
controversy the story goes that bill
engineered the pandemic in order to
benefit financially and track people but
some common sense would make it clear
that this doesn't make sense the vaccine
is estimated to cost between 3 and 37
per dose depending on which vaccine you
get let's estimate in the middle and
call it 20 per dose or forty dollars to
get fully vaccinated using pfizer's net
margin of twenty to twenty five percent
you could expect to make about ten
dollars from each vaccination
even if bill was somehow able to
vaccinate half of the entire world's
population he would only make forty
billion dollars that is a large sum of
money but you have to look at it from
bill's perspective
he's literally donated over 45 billion
dollars and he's already made 18.3
billion dollars in 2021 alone through
public stock ownership and we're only 8
months into the year
so if anything 40 billion dollars is a
couple of years of stock growth for bill
and it makes no sense to ruin his
reputation over this money
as for the tracking theory well bill did
create microsoft so if he wanted to
track everyone i suspect leveraging the
billions of windows users around the
world would be much easier than
vaccinating the world
as you can see in my opinion this theory
holds little weight nonetheless many
people have bought into it and it has
significantly fueled the bill gets
controversy bill's foundation isn't the
only thing smearing his public
reputation though the other black spot
on his record is his relationship with
jeff according to the new york times
bill met with jeff at least three times
since 2011.
at the time jeff's crimes were already
pretty well known
he pleaded guilty in 2008 and had
already spent extensive time in jail
so the question is why bill gates was
willing to meet with such an individual
according to bill jeff was well
connected within the business world and
bill was looking to raise money for his
foundation with the help of jeff
apparently jeff was willing to raise
money from all of his wealthy friends in
exchange for 0.3 percent of the total
money he raised bill claims that his
relationship with jeff was strictly
business bill never went to any parties
with jeff and all of their meetings were
almost entirely just men
despite this critics argued that bill
was at the very least compliant with
jeff's actions or else why would he meet
with someone with such a history
after all he's bill gates one of the
most well-known billionaires alive
what type of connections could jeff
possibly provide that bill couldn't just
get himself
while that is a big questionable it
should be noted that bill gates cut the
relationship in 2014 and he never
actually received any money from jeff
bill's recent divorce with melinda
however has resurfaced concerns about
bill and jeff's relationship bill and
melinda have both been pretty obscure
about the reasoning behind their
separation
and this has sparked speculation that
melinda got a divorce because she was
uncomfortable with bill
melinda apparently hated bill's
relationship with jeff and she strongly
disagreed with how bill handled an
internal case of harassment as bill
stepped away from microsoft he shifted
all of his wealth to a wealth management
company called cascade investments which
was managed by a man named michael
larson
michael has obviously done a spectacular
job when it comes to growing bill's
wealth but his personal life is not as
pristine
in 2017 a woman threatened to file a
lawsuit against michael for harassment
but instead of addressing the situation
bill basically paid her off and michael
still manages bill's wealth to this day
this case wasn't revealed to the public
for quite some time and many speculate
that melinda might know something about
bill and jeff's relationship that we
don't and that's why she actually left
bill
so is the controversy surrounding bill
legitimate
at this point we just don't know
the rule has always been innocent until
proven guilty though so i don't think we
should jump to any conclusions sure he
had some weird allocations of funds and
he's extremely tired about his
intellectual property but these aren't
crimes by any means moreover even with
these obstacles bill has done more for
humanity than most billionaires at the
top
so i think he at least deserves the
benefit of the doubt this does not mean
that bill gets a full-on free pass
though the two main sticking points are
his foundation's potential violation of
medical ethics and bill's relationship
with jeff until we have a definitive
answer regarding these concerns though i
see no reason to paint bill in a
negative light do you guys think the
bill gates controversy has merit comment
that down below
also drop a like if you thought this
video outlined the concerns well
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one